when the economics goes bad we become
vulnerable to bad ideas on the inside
flap you have something here that I
thought just summed up almost every
reason that I do this show and talk
about these issues and and love what you
do it says we're living through a
postmodern era in which the grand
narratives of religion and political
ideology have collapse in their place
have emerged a crusading desire to write
perceived wrongs and a weaponization of
identity both accelerated by the new
forms of social and news media narrow
sets of interests now dominate the
agenda as society becomes more and more
tribal and as Marie shows the casualties
are mounting
now I'm gonna slowly take off my glasses
how was that that was pretty good right
I'm like a leaf of like Anderson Cooper
know that that little synopsis right
there I think is exactly what's on
everyone's mind these days that a small
few have somehow taken over all of the
narratives so I guess my first question
would be when when do you think this all
started
I think it's a phenomenon of the last
decade I think that it starts in earnest
after the financial crash of 2008 you
know we when we look back at history
causes of revolutions and so on we know
that when the economics goes bad other
things happen and I think that we
pretend at the moment as if the crash
sort of didn't happen or didn't have an
effect in our culture and of course it
didn't cause something like that's going
to and I say in the introduction to the
madness of crowds you know it's not a
surprise that young people who can't
accumulate capital capital in their
lives don't have any particular love of
capitalism and it's not surprising that
a generation that finds it incredibly
hard to get on the property ladder for
instance is going to be susceptible to
ideologies that claim to be able to
solve every inequity on earth so my view
is that that when the economics goes bad
we become vulnerable to bad ideas and
the ones I write about in the madness of
crowds
I think these ideas have been gestating
since at least the 1980s these things
that we now know is identity politics
intersectionality possibly the ugliest
word in the language and and these has
been these have been hanging around
since about the 80s but they only come
flooding in in the last decade and then
in the last five years as you can prove
I lay out some of it in the book in the
last five years that's when all this
stuff actually became weaponized yeah
and when it started to be used as a real
battering ram alright so first off thank
you for actually saying the title of the
book that was very unprofessional to me
it is called the madness of crowds you
are correct right there so that's it
that's an interesting theory that you've
laid out that basically these ideas
these sort of bad ideas and and
totalitarian ideas that they've been
sitting there but it takes something
else in this case an economic crash to
bring them up to the fold so you think
if the crash had not happened you think
that basically would have been a buffer
to just kind of keep these ideas under
our normal layer of discourse well I
think so I mean the you know
it's been on my mind for many years as
I've noticed this sort of intrusion into
the public space of these ideas and of
these weaponized identity groupings of
people being used against each other you
know gay people seeming to be used for
something to hit straight people and
people of different races being used
against each other and women being used
against men you know this sort of this
horrible thing we've been through in
recent years so many times and yeah when
I started looking into the intellectual
origins of some of this I sort of
assumed that there were serious texts
and that these these these these ideas
came from a serious place and I was sort
of stunned and I started looking into it
that really it's it's a lot of
assertions that are being made in these
texts you know there's a famous
foundational text of intersectionality
called unpacking the knapsack packing
the invisible knapsack and I sort of
thought this by a professor Wellesley I
sort of thought well well this must be
some kind of serious you know attempt at
something I might be wrong but no it's
not it's a few pages of assertions and
that started to make me particularly
interested so I thought well how did how
did a few assertions by one Wells the
academic become a sort of one of the
basis for something that is now being
tried out everywhere and and the real
shock to me as I was researching this
book was this isn't just you know it
broke out from these four liberal arts
colleges like you know Wellesley and a
few sort of places like Berkeley when
Judith Barlow and this sort of stuff it
broke out from there but we now see it
being flooding through among other
things the corporate world and that was
a huge I mean I'm just amazed the extent
to which is has gone through that now
and you know this but but the only
people who don't think that this stuff
is coming towards them are people who
are basically self-employed and don't
have much connection with other people
in an office or anything but everybody
else knows that through human resources
departments commitments to diversity all
of this sort of thing and this is all
coming for them and I'm just I'm just
amazed as I say that a set of ideas
which is we'll come on to it provable
wrong are provably not gonna work and
contradictory
self-contradiction it's just amazing to
me that this should have flooded through
governments corporations as if it's
something that might work when it can't
when you were doing the research for the
book and you found some of these
documents which as they're talking about
the genesis of intersectionality it's a
couple pages basically in a weird way
would you have preferred to have found a
solid foundation to argue against you
know something that even if you
disagreed with all of the outcomes that
you would have been able to fight in
sort of like an even way as opposed to
fighting something that because it's not
foundational you're just kind of
fighting all over the place right that's
what I assumed I thought I thought this
is gonna require some you know serious
delving and so on and I I just say I was
amazed at this but what's more I mean I
mean you know the academia bit in a way
is is the most sortie Dias part of it
for obvious reasons because once it
breaks into the pop culture world for
instance you know then it then it became
we have talked about mass mass
entertainment and indeed I think mass
derangement when some of these ideas go
into the pop cultural world well but but
but these are these claims made the
foundational claims are among other
things written in the type of academic
jargon that is so bad that it's clear
that it is prose intended only to do one
of two things the first is to hide a
meaning because there isn't one and the
second one is to write this badly
because the author knows that what
they're saying isn't true and they're
trying to cover over the fact but I mean
I mean I give examples and and I did the
audio book for this book and I mean just
reading some of them out aloud I mean
like I kept corpsing uh
in the sound booth because I mean they
are such ridiculously badly written
texts and and as I say I mean I give
examples but this is a real this is
fraudulence on a massive scale
okay well here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna dive into it and there one
of the beauties of the book actually is
the way you lay it out is such
simplicity
in fact you really only have four
chapters here which then you have some
interludes for but it's really four main
ideas but I'm going to put my fake
glasses on for just one more moment here
because I want to read the two quotes at
the beginning of the book because I feel
you've you started us off beautifully
here you said it's this is a quote the
special mark of the modern world is not
that it is skeptical but that it is
dogmatic without knowing it that's G K
Chesterton and then uh this next one oh
my gosh look at her butt oh my gosh look
at her butt oh my gosh look at her butt
look at her butt look at it look at it
look at it look at her butt by Nicki
Minaj and Minaj and Minaj Douglas why
those two quotes and now I'm putting the
glasses away my friend yeah that's
that's the epigraph page I I sort of
thought it did signaled what I was
planning to do why I hope I have done in
the book which is in part to just show
people what's going on I go in the
chapter in women I go into the issue of
miss Minaj
but yeah well let's hold that for a
second yeah the GK Chesterton quote it
seems to me incredibly opposite to the
point I'm trying to make you know that
that that we have extraordinary set of
dogmas in our time whereas dogmatic as
any age but it requires I think you know
somebody to step back and say what are
the dogmas and I I just have decided
that it was worth putting him down the
four that I see most closely gay which
is the first chapter women the second
the third is race and the fourth is
trans and we we basically if I could sum
up what I'm trying to do with this and
I'm not sure it's that I think we are
pretending to know about things we don't
know about
and we're pretending not to know about
things we all knew til yesterday and
this these two things simultaneously are
one of the reasons why our societies are
dementing ourselves if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell